If it's like this, even if I kill Donmai,
it's
fine
naoaname Who
is that?
[Music]
Collecting delicious insects,
wind,
come on, come on, come on, come on
!
My
letts The typeface color of the equipment
There are many other things, so let's do our best with everyone in the class
Don't come to see your father and mother.
I'm going to be praised for this Oh,
I got this It
's okay It's
delicious ーー
509 Naka Park
[Music]
Let's meet Grandpa Wong
Dai Japanese No, go with
that design
Jab and Ishige
Boo Boo
sar
So I definitely don't know anymore I like it suddenly
You're backing up, this is Togi
[music]
That's why you
can't buy money unless it belongs to this group
I
'll go tomorrow
I've finally ordered the
Komuraimono riser ok
Two omelet rice
[music]
boof
[music
] n
goo
[music]
blue weak Summer vacation homework
What
should I do?
Why don't you study what you want to know I
see.
Discussion
What are you doing?